hey everybody this is quincy with free
code camp I've had a lot of requests
from a lot of code campers to show how I
use Gmail as you may have heard I use
gmail maybe five or ten minutes a day
but during that period of time I read
all kinds of emails and respond and the
key is using keyboard shortcuts that
saves so much time so let's take a look
at some of the shortcuts I'm going to
teach you real quick so basically
navigating around gmail opening replying
replying to all the emails forward and
composing and archiving and even
marketing spam we're going to learn all
that real quick so the first thing you
want to do is go to gmail this is just a
kind of spam email account that i use
and you'll want to go to settings and
you'll want to find keyboard shortcuts
and you'll want to make sure the
keyboard shortcuts are on and then you
want to save so after you do that you
can go back to the inbox you and this is
my main view I don't actually use a lot
of folders or any of the advanced gmail
functionality i literally just use the
inbox in my actual inboxes inbox zero I
always have a completely empty and
anything that I can't deal with
immediately when I figure out some way
to get it back into the court of another
person or I set up a reminder to take
action in the future but specifically in
the realm of hot keys I'm going to teach
you immediately something very useful
Jay will move this blue cursor here down
okay we'll move it back up it's a
fundamental concept that you should
grasp and using these gmail shortcuts
another thing you should know Oh will
open an email so as you can see I've got
this original email it's just a email
here I can click on it to open it up i
can click it to close it but i can also
use n to move to the next one and pee to
move to the previous one like it just
hit enter to expand it if i want so n is
next p is previous okay so let's go back
to
the inbox here and i'm going to show you
if i open it up i can hit Jay to shift
through all the different emails I have
in my inbox and I can hit k to move back
and when i get to the very top and i hit
k the final time it just takes me right
back to the inbox so i can go really
deep come right back up into the inbox
next thing i want to show you is how to
compose emails you can see and you can
compose an email and you can just hit
tab to skip through the fields let's say
you wanted to send an email to somebody
you just tap down here you just hit tab
and they they lock in that email address
and you can type your next email address
tab down here test test hit tab again
and you see that it highlights send you
just hit enter and it's set so now let's
go ahead and reply to an email so I've
got this email I'm just going to hit our
to reply to it I can hit escape at any
point to exit out of this text box that
I'm in and get access to these hot keys
again let's do that so I'm going to hit
escape and I'm going to hit a and I'm
going to reply to all this particular
email only has one Center so it's not
any different from replying the other
thing i could do is i can hit escape to
exit out of this and instead of replying
i can hit f2 forward it i can forward it
to an email address and you'll notice
how i just type team and hit tab there
and it auto completed the rest so tab is
gmail has something called tab
completion you can hit tab to complete
email addresses then I can just hit tab
and send a little message and then hit
tab again and hit enter to send it so
then after I've done all this stuff I
can either hit Jay to go all the way
back up to the top or okay to go all the
way back to the top or I can archive it
but before we start archiving things
because this is pretty critical you can
hit X to select the currently selected
email and it'll add this little check to
this
box here so what you can do is you can
just hit Jay XJ xjx you can just select
the time of stuff and then you can hit
yo archive it and that's what I do I
don't actually create folders or
anything I just archive things and
that's how I get 20 inbox our kind of
stuff the other thing I wanted to show
you is you can hit if you hit X you can
just hit ! and it will mark it as spam
now I don't actually want to mark this
as spam so I can just undo that with Z
so regardless of how deep you get
yourself and you can always hit Z to
undo it so that's how I use gmail and
gmail is a wonderful tool you don't need
some powerful email app if you just know
a few shortcuts and if you just go
through really quickly and our kind of
things you don't want and last thing is
a goody little grab-bag item if you hit
/ it'll select the text box so you can
just start typing let's just search test
and we'll find the previous emails I
sent with test is the subject and the
content so that's how I use gmail thanks
for watching